so when i have my meeting with them they
say okay courtney this is how we're
gonna do it we're gonna have a
three-year program with you i said okay
he said you you're number one
is the year of yes
you say yes to every single job that
comes your way
your film career later in life as you
did how do you think your mindset is
different
um
starting later
with my film career my mindset
is i'm very focused
and i know what i want
and i feel a lot more confident
and how to go about getting it
um
and
i'm not afraid to ask for it
you know to ask for the order so to
speak
i think probably in the past i would
have been nervous i would have been
afraid to
you know
hit up imdb
find the producer hit them up i probably
am afraid to to do that but now i'm not
afraid at all so i think
i just have this confidence in me
because i've lived life
and uh yeah i'm not afraid
so since 2018 is this correct that
you've directed over 20 episodes of
television okay and then three made for
tv movies and you've also written
scripts that have been produced
since 2018 what's your secret
um
going back to the uh the will um
will smith adage of
um you know there'll be other
screenwriters other directors that are
more talented than me
but i won't be outworked
and it comes down to the work
it literally just comes down to the work
and
taking advantage and leveraging the
relationships that i do have
you know though they're not a lot
it's afforded me the opportunity to
be a part of all these different
projects and so
um
you know
being a good person
being a person that people can count on
um
being on time uh being courteous you
know the basics that your mother and
father taught you
that does carry a long way in this
business because there's so many jerks
and
you know when you are that way people
want to continue to work with you and so
that's what allowed that's what allowed
me to kind of do that um
you know some of it is right place right
time
but it doesn't matter if you're not
prepared to do the work
you know so there's a little bit of luck
involved with that of course
but no i put the work in and you know
even today like so for example
um
there's a so the show that i that i
write on um and i've directed a lot of
episodes of tv on
it's called saints and centers
so they're going to their sixth season
right now i've directed
i've written on season four
season five
and i wrote on season six
i directed season four
four episodes season five eight episodes
and season six i thought i was gonna
direct but then in the last minute they
said i wasn't gonna direct they're gonna
have someone else direct but i wrote two
of the episodes two two of the eight
episodes
um
it's it's a situation where
even though i didn't get the job to
direct it
i'm always hitting him up say okay guys
what's next what can we work on next so
i i i keep that communication going
because nobody's going to just give you
anything
it's that whole out of sight out of mind
situation
you don't want to you don't want to be a
nuisance but
what you want to do is you want to
remind people that you know what hey
you're available you know and the
company that i've worked with in the
past they do a lot of work so it's like
don't forget you know i'm around so
let's go shoot something together
okay so let's suppose a new filmmaker um
whether they're new age-wise or just
career-wise um it's polite it's not that
they're difficult to work with but
they're just too picky do you see that
where
new new talent is just too picky and
maybe they need to
take jobs that they may not necessarily
want to take
in the beginning that's a good question
have i seen people that were too picky i
have not seen that personally however
for those of you that are out there that
are that way
um
so i just joined um
an agency they're called the gersh
agency they're they're a pretty big
boutique agency really great actors are
attached to them but they do um literary
directing like jk jk simmons is there
like i love jk simmons he's a great
actor right so he's he's with a girls
agency
so when i have my meeting with them they
say okay courtney this is how we're
gonna do it we're gonna have a
three-year program with you i said okay
he said
you're number one
is the year of yes
you say yes to every single job that
comes your way
the idea behind that is that
because
you are trying to expand your network
you're trying to expand your resume
you take every single job no matter what
it is
um and then from there you'll know what
you like what kind of work you like and
what kind of work you don't like so that
a year number two
you could say the year of no and the
year of no
is where you now you can be picky
because you know you've done everything
that you wanted to do you said yes to
everything in the year number one but
year number two is the year of no
and what that means is that now you can
be picky
when you're new you can't afford to be
picky it's the point i'm trying to make
you can't afford to be picky you need to
say yes to everything because you are
still trying to expand your network
no you may not want to do a christmas
movie
no you may not do you may not want to do
a woman in peril movie
but
by doing that you're getting to meet
producers
cinematographers
um
and other people who are on the crew
who may recommend you for something else
in the future that is more to your
liking whether it's horror or some other
genre um
project
so
that's what that's about so then in the
year three my agent was like
in the year three now
you've established and by the way
hollywood is very intrigued with anybody
that says no
you say no they're like okay who's this
person like what's going on here like i
want to know more tell me more and so
that's why they said year the year two
now year three i will be in a better
situation to
pitch
in uh my own original projects
because i've established my own
relationships people know who i am
um i'm not all over the place
doing a whole bunch of stuff and so when
i come with these original ideas that i
have that i'm i'm developing right now
they'll be more uh apt and ready to
listen to me
interesting so that i love that so year
one is yes your two is no and then year
three it sounds like it's more
self-driven yeah these are my projects
yes i'm saying yes
to my process yes oh interesting i like
that i'm like wow that's kind of cool
that is great and so they they train you
at the i mean they're they're kind of
like coaching you along with sending you
out yeah exactly right so they've sent
me out a lot of general meetings i met
with a lot of great people um
and the great thing about it is that i i
i am currently working on developing
projects that are mine that are very
personal
let me take a little sure sure no they
don't mind that are very personal
um
and they want to see these projects
which is great now i'm not expecting
these projects to be made
but they'll be very good work samples in
case they want to staff me as a writer
on one of their projects so
yeah you're getting you're going to get
a lot of opportunities by saying yes
your first year
and is one of those projects the one
that's about your life story
that's the one that they want to see
they want to read that because they i
told them about it and they're like oh
my god i want to read it so
i just finished my um
first draft i got my notes back and i'm
gonna go back and over the next two
weeks work on that
do you mind sharing some of the notes
um
sure i don't mind um
so again it's loosely based upon my life
when i was going to this performing arts
high school
um
and some of the notes from my managers
have to do with
uh
so when you write for television
typically you're gonna have for like a
one hour show you'll have five acts
sometimes you'll have 5x and like a
teaser in the very beginning i have 5x
and i think it's in act 4.
we're spending a lot of time at this
party
um
so the idea is that it's it's it's a
character based upon me
and then i come in contact with these
other people at this school
and we become friends so i needed an
event to bring them all together because
when courtney goes to this school you
know my character goes to the school
he's the new guy
they've already been going to the school
for halfway into the semester
so i'm coming in at the halfway point of
the semester right around you know the
winter the winter break
so they already know each other and so
he becomes friends with one person who
who introduces him to all these other
people so i needed an event so
i bring him all together at a party
and that's how he kind of becomes
friends with all these other people
so the note that i got from my managers
uh was you know we like that
let's shorten it a little bit and i want
to spend more time with courtney at home
what is his home
situation like what is his what is
relation with his parents like his
sisters
his brother
what's that like and what's going on
there
and so i'm like yeah that's a that's
really a good point because what i
wanted to do was i'm taking each of
these characters um there's five main
characters
um you're introducing
in the pilot is is is the character
based upon me but the other four
characters we're going to spend time
with them as well
um and i want to see what their dynamic
at home is
is that
is as well so
that's why they wanted to have
that go on they wanted me to kind of
spend time with this courtney kind of
character at home to see what his home
life was like
so did you just want to show more of the
fun
side going to parties and and engaging
with people from school and they wanted
to see
um kind of what shaped you correct
you're 100 right and so
because of the fact that we're going to
spend
time with
these kids
at fun things
uh seeing them do fun things seeing them
in in the school as they try to you know
really strive at this performing arts
school um
we were going to get that at some point
in other episodes but definitely wanted
to kind of like really understand where
these people were coming from and what
drove them to uh to this point now there
is some funny game stuff in there um
there's a little there's a little bit of
magical realism when they perform it's
it's you know it's a very fun
uh show um
but i mean i had the whole fourth act
was the party which is like 12 pages
where i can make that into six pages at
the party
and then another the other six six pages
i can devote that to
courtney's relationship with you know
with his family
so that was
some of the notes the shorten the party
scene and show us more backstory sure of
the home has anyone said you know what
it's too hard to write a a a realistic
narrative about yourself
you're too close to it
no one's ever told me that it's too hard
to write um a narrative about myself
because i'm too close to it no
and in fact i was encouraged to do this
this actually so funny because when i
when i got my managers in 2018
the first thing i told them was that i
don't want to i do not want to direct a
dance movie
and i said because typically the dance
movies that i that
are done
i don't like
um
they're typically about the dance but
not the story
i said the kind of stuff that i like is
like all that jazz you know
um a chronographer who does coke and
sleeps with his you know with his with
his dancers like that's the kind of
stuff that i like i like a little more
darker stuff and the other stuff was a
little bit too pop corny you know for me
um
so initially i said no and so they've
always wanted me to write this story
but i said no
because
number one it was very close to me i was
afraid and i didn't think i was i
i didn't know a way into the story
that's that was going to be unique
you know so initially the story was just
going to be about a bunch of kids who go
to performing arts school i'm like okay
we've seen fame we we've seen this done
like what's so different what's so
special and i couldn't find a way to
break it
and then i said
why don't i just base it upon me and
people that i know
we'll change the names and everything
but that's what we'll do
because those stories are unique
you know and so i said okay that's the
way to break in so then i started
breaking down how to make that happen
and uh i did my beat sheet my outline
and i just you know turned in my first
draft